Touren semble épargner c'est d'ailleurs
le sens de notre question web les
punaises de lit ont envahi les médias
mais avez-vous vu ces insectes chez vous
ou dans les lieux publics vous êtes
seulement 2 % à répondre par
l'affirmative un constat partagé par les
professionnels de la
désinsectisation et quelques
interventions supplémentaires contre les
punaises mais enfin pas de quoi fouetter
un chat alors si toutefois vous croisez
la petite bébette Aurée Renault n vous
dit comment
agir l'irby c'est l'Institut de
recherche sur la biologie des insectes
la punae de lit fait partie des sujets
d'étude du professeur Claudio Lazzari un
insecte gros comme un pépin de pomme
très actif la nuit dont la quête est de
nous piquer pour se nourrir de notre
sang et chaque individus à une espérance
de vie moyenne des an ça ça dépend un
peu des conditions de s'il peut se
nourrir fréquemment au moins fréquemment
sont très tolérantes à la manque des des
nourritures et et donc peut rester un
peu pe caché un mobile même si une pièce
n'est pas utilisée pendant pendant
plusieurs mois donc la paise va rester
toujours caché en attente il y a
quelqu'un qui qui qui vient qui puisse
qui puisse piquer sbastien Fouret est
spécialiste de la lutte antiparasitaire
en indrloire depuis 12 ans aujourd'hui
chez lui deux interventions sur 10 sont
lié à la Puna de lit un chiffre en
légère hausse ces derniers mois mais on
est bien loin de l'infestation don dont
on parle dans certaines villes en France
ce qui a grimpé en flèche c'est le
nombre d'appels de personnes inquiètes
quand le cas est avéré la pièce est
entièrement traitée dans ses moindres
recoins pour environ 400 €. mais avant
toute intervention une astuce vous
permet de savoir si ce sont bien des
punaises de lit qui se sont installé
chez vous vous prenez un petit chiffon
humide un petit sopalin quelque chose
d'humide et vous venez frotter ces
petites traces noires euh qui dit
excrément de punaise dit présence de
sang donc si vous avez du sang ça va
devenir orangé rougeâtre si ça reste
marron noir vous êtes sur autre chose
vous êtes sur de la mouche sur quelque
chose d'autre qui qui n'est pas de la
punae enfin le professionnel recommande
un lavage à 60° ou encore la congélation
durant 2 jours de tout textile en
contact avec des punaises et parfois un
changement de la literie semble
impératif